our political elite did not really step
up to the plate it wasn't much of a
peace process was it today's taliban are
angry but you can't lay all the blame at
the u.s talk we we probably didn't do a
good job however you spin the story of
afghanistan and there are plenty of
versions these days the country is back
where it was 20 years ago firmly under
taliban control
but no one is quite sure what kind of
regime this is who's pulling its strings
what about its terrorist connections and
its links to the narcotics trade is it
as cruel and repressive as it used to be
my guest this week has seen the taliban
at close quarters he's jawed luden a
former adviser to ex-president hamid
karzai and deputy foreign minister in
his government he joins me from ottawa
what of the new rulers got in store for
the afghan people does the west have any
effective leverage will anyone ever
answer for the war crimes of the last 20
years
[Music]
jawad luden welcome to conflict zone
you're welcome thank you
last month you told a television program
you were in a state of shock about the
taliban's takeover in kabul i can't
believe it's happened you said
why the shock mr lubin wasn't it obvious
what would happen when the americans
pulled out
perhaps when the americans pulled out
but
it didn't have to even even even in the
west case scenario didn't really have to
happen the way it did
uh the pulldown didn't have to mean
a military victory and a takeover
of kabul by by the taliban it could have
happened in a more responsible
uh manner uh the transition could have
happened in a responsible manner and i
think the americans could have
handled the the the peace process that
they were engaged in for the for the
last three years almost
and in a better way that could have uh
that this scenario could have been
avoided if you've enjoyed this interview
please share your comments below and
give it a like you might also take a
look back at my interview with the last
afghan president ashraf ghani just click
on the link
it wasn't much of a peace process was it
i mean donald trump basically handed the
taliban afghanistan over the heads of
the afghan government didn't he
well i don't know how
what their intentions were part of the
the problem is exactly that for the last
20 years we have been unclear about what
the true intentions of the americans
were
for that matter i use the word american
but i mean the the broader western
coalition led by the united states
and in this particular case the peace
process was it was a was a very good
opportunity in fact they uh to the
extent that they were talking
about the u.s
taliban
issues which was basically about the
withdrawal about the end of the conflict
about
[Music]
some of the other
issues that they had
in fact the negotiations worked very
well it's just that the u.s
too soon removed the leverage that it
had on the battlefield as well as
diplomatically
by by by concluding the agreement uh in
a way that uh basically gives taliban
all the
all the power all the leverage
and then made the peace process the
remaining peace process which was with
the afghan side
um rendering it meaningless as you as
you said one of the countries that seems
to have known all along what was going
on is pakistan and you've been scathing
in your criticism of islamabad over the
years in may you said it had proved for
20 years that it could deceive the world
and that it had always played a double
game in afghanistan in your view did
pakistan mastermind the taliban take
over
i believe so i believe there are
the one consistent aspect of the
conflict in afghanistan and mind you the
the you know when
the thing that you call the afghan
conflict
uh
not only in the last 20 years but even
before that has always had these um
three layers of um
of of of factors the domestic factors
the regional factors and the
international factors
but on pakistan what's your evidence for
saying they they masterminded the
takeover pakistan has always denied
giving military assistance to the
taliban
well i mean i'm surprised we are having
this uh
discussing this question when even the
pakistanis today do not deny that so it
doesn't have to be so the burden of
proof is on them
to just basically um
uh
prove that that that was uh that was not
the case when uh when it's it's
completely evident the taliban leaders
have lived there um all along in the
last 20 years their
headquarters their center of operations
has always been in quetta that the
taliban leaders even to this day they're
um
they're injured uh
have been taken there for treatment um
but that's i think it's a bit too late
to really discuss that and
honestly i don't know what what benefit
is there uh to do that it is it is what
it is we are where we are the important
thing is now to
even even if pakistan's rule is
completely uh critical and
maybe it's useful to engage them at this
stage and see if if we can get a better
solution in afghanistan because the way
things are going in afghanistan may
actually
end up being
completely detrimental to pakistani
security as well it's just that some
elements in pakistan don't seem to
to to know this or even to carry care
about it because in pakistan as well you
know pakistan is controlled by a by by
an institution by an overpowerful
military and i think it's really a lot
of times it's the interest the corporate
interests of the military that trample
the interests of the pakistani people
thanks for watching conflict zone on
youtube if you enjoyed the show please
share it and follow the link to the
playlist of previous interviews mr ludin
as far as the west is concerned does
nato's withdrawal mean that it is no
longer a player in the region that it's
pretty much lost all the leverage it had
in afghanistan
and the wider area i think significantly
yes uh
the
let's remember that for a long time for
the last 20 years
nato uh
and
the united states in particular has had
a the most important uh leverage over
events in afghanistan the direction of
the things the developments
um um
taking place
um but today that precisely for the
reason that we discussed earlier for the
way that this whole transition or the
withdrawal was conducted
um that leverage is no longer there in
its repo for two reasons uh we and
basically the evidence that we see
number one that the regional or the
region has has replaced that that that
influence
we're talking about russia china iran
pakistan
correct um and in some other states as
well like i mean small states like qatar
for example today seem to have
um
significant influence
even more so then
if by influence we mean you know
whatever the taliban will actually
listen to them the other fire the other
evidence we see is the fact that the
taliban
um
see absolutely no reason to
um to take seriously what uh what the
west is telling them because they for
them the relationship with the west is
optional they would prefer it they would
really like the seat in the united
nations in new york
they would like to have the embassies
and have the recognition but it's easier
to do business with russia and china
isn't it because they're not going to
impose any conditions like human rights
for instance are they so it's much
easier it doesn't come the aid if it
comes from china and russia won't have
any strings attached to it will it
and even if the aid doesn't come i don't
think the taliban really are
let's remember for 20 years they've um
and even more so even at the time when
they were in power in the 90s taliban
have been essentially a military machine
uh
consistently in conflict and they have
relatively little if if anything uh
of experience
um in terms of governing uh the country
and and
in that kind of a situation they've
they've really not yet
um
developed themselves into into a
political institution and therefore they
don't
seem to be amenable to public pressure
to
to things like you know that's why
that's why using sometimes the argument
about using humanitarian aid or aid in
general as um
you know as a pressure on the taliban it
kind of makes me it makes me wonder
these you know not many people seem to
understand the taliban for them it
probably is just it's an optional thing
if they have it they
they would be happy if they don't have
it they would just consider it as a as
the will of god and they they really as
a as a deeply religious institution
they will just see that it's god's uh
willing and god's responsibility to feed
the poor people
uh mr ludwig when you look at what
defeated the afghan army you do have to
mention the rampant corruption in the
country that sapped people's loyalty and
their will to fight
in in 2009 according to transparency
international out of 180 countries only
somalia was listed as more corrupt than
afghanistan over the years it hasn't
been a proud record has it this
corruption
uh no sadly it hasn't uh and really that
in a way was a significant factor in the
downfall of the of the islamic republic
um
tragically
i would also say add that though the
the way that this whole thing has been
been portrayed in the west is also
incorrect um
imagine that a massive aid industry
comes into play um
billions of dollars flow into a totally
impoverished country a country that
doesn't have the institutions of state
to
to handle it
um i think corruption is the is the
the obvious uh consequence
um but you can't play all the blame at
the u.s store can you it's like a
burglar breaking into a rich man's house
and claiming it's the owner's fault to
having so much money in the first place
i i never do i never blame the us um
at least
you know a
significant thing i think is the afghan
sport
i think we afghans
do tend sometimes to
take far less responsibility than than
is due to us um this was after all an
opportunity a totally absolutely
historic opportunity unrepeatable in
history for us to really make our
country
um into a good normal
society and and we failed and corruption
is is one of the factors
uh but i think there were other factors
as well the fact that the the
leadership the crisis of leadership that
we had our political elite did not
really step up to the plate and and a
good example was our just the runaway
president that we had if you've enjoyed
this interview please share your
comments below and give it a like you
might also take a look back at my
interview with the last afghan president
ashraf ghani just click on the link
will you you served the president before
him um hamid karzai
in 2010 the royal institute for
international affairs chatham house
accused karzai's government of actively
undermining the rule of law and
accountability do you quarrel with that
judgment
no i don't i myself the
the country uh
under his leadership um i admire him
still for a lot of qualities for courage
um
um for the fact that he was a factor of
unity and still is to this day but
pardoned drug smugglers didn't he
rapists and taliban commanders
you know he muted key anti-corruption
bodies as well as watering down
electoral monitoring after the polls
have been marked by fraud so there was a
long list of things that he did to
undermine the rule of law wasn't there
i was going to come to that yes the so
there is the uh
the you know the
corruption in a lot of the really the
fundamentals of
of
of the building of state could have been
uh could have been done better under
under his term um and we wouldn't be
here today so i think a significant part
of the blame
um also goes to
you know to those of us and not for for
the little role that i had i would be
happy to uh
accept that that we we probably didn't
do a good job um i would however just
just point out that i don't think he is
corrupt personally um i think he made an
error of judgment by
by basically
putting
the need for unity at that time ahead of
of reform and ahead of
state building
which is the mistake that
the the president after him
repeated in exactly the opposite order
because at the time when
when unity was most needed
he just went and uh
under false slogans or fighting
corruption but the the fact is mr ludin
hamid karzai turned the presidency into
a kind of family cash cow didn't he at
least six relatives were operating in or
were linked to contracting businesses
that collected millions of dollars from
the americans and even his cousin
muhammad karzai who lived in the u.s
pointed the finger at him and said the
karzai's over there in afghanistan are
cashing in on their last name my
relatives told me they can't understand
why i don't come over with them and get
rich
this was a kleptocracy wasn't it let's
give it its
proper name
um well first of all that you know the
last time i i worked in in the
government under president karzai was in
twitter it was more than 10 years ago
and i don't speak for him today
so it would be good that these questions
are addressed to
somebody closer but however i do um
agree i think i think the same
was was done uh sadly under the the
president that followed him um
[Music]
do you those family connections played a
huge role which again in in a society
like afghanistan in the absence of
strong institutions i think that's
probably what happens these uh you know
tribal relationship family relationships
tend to
um
[Music]
here in the west you have um you have
political parties that probably
are the modern form of form of of tribe
tribes that we have there in afghanistan
um
it is there's not much comparison though
is there there's not much comparison
let's be honest
well corruption takes place in every
society yes but it's it's it was the
degree of it it was the degree of it i
mean politicians were building their
poppy palaces they were wheeling uh
suitcases with a million dollars in cash
through the airport um karzai himself
was receiving suitcases of cash from the
cia wasn't he on a regular basis wasn't
he
well what i did say that uh tim that
that is a major factor in the downfall
of the republic i started by saying this
is corruption and those are just
examples that you're mentioning and i
could even give you more i'd like to
look at if we may at the way forward
because your your think tank the heart
of asia society says the taliban should
continue to practice restraint from
unilaterally establishing their emirate
they've also emphasized they'll accept a
system that is inclusive it's critical
that the taliban stand by these promises
we we haven't seen much of restraint so
far from the taliban have we targeted
killings like the murder of a radio
station manager in kabul the beating of
un staff the looting of un offices
shooting at
women and beating them and
demonstrations income there isn't much
restraint there is it this is this isn't
taliban light is it point of reference
really is the taliban in the 1990s so if
you compare it
and in in many ways they have behaved
the same in fact even worse executions
are continuing um in areas captured by
the taliban attacks against former and
current government officials as well as
their family members no restraint there
is there exactly so the thing one thing
that has changed for the worse uh since
90s is the fact that today's taliban are
angry they have a very deep seated
vengeance that they will unleash um and
and they see there are examples that
that has taken place on the other hand
uh
there was an opportunity and the
statements that you referred to from
from our organization
was really
focused on the opportunities that that
they were the reason we saw and and
sadly we see
less of that now and that was the fact
the taliban refrained from declaring
their their their islamic emirate at the
beginning that they engaged in some sort
of negotiation they reached out to some
people
we saw that as an opportunity i think
those opportunities are increasingly
you know disappearing and and and i
think that would be another historic
mistake um in one that the taliban did
have an opportunity to really
switch from from a military focus into
one of you know establishing a
good
form of governance
an inclusive form of governments but it
seems that
when you when you're talking about
establishing um
their future and uh who they're going to
deal with they're dealing with al qaeda
aren't they um one of the and and it's
regional offshoots who are busy
celebrating what they call the defeat of
america um
these are still close relationships
between the taliban and terrorist groups
like al-qaeda that's not going away is
it
again you have to see it in a number of
ways
one is that the historia that is an
historic relationship between taliban
and al-qaeda and you know why the 9 11
attack uh that was planned from
afghanistan uh tragically at the time
and and how the taliban refused to hand
over some bin laden in the 90s or in the
beginning of the of of the century and
that was why the the
intervention took place in afghanistan
today where that stand obviously taliban
have made some commitments and they know
that there will be consequences to that
um
in terms of breaking away from from al
qaeda but but let me just point out one
clear thing as far as i can i see it
extremist organizations throughout the
region not just in afghanistan are
essentially part of the same
this the same broad network whether it's
al-qaeda whether it's
even even isis
the islamic state today
is i mean the taliban seem to be
fighting them on the ground but i
actually don't see them as being
fundamentally
opposite um
unless unless the taliban breaks their
ties with al qaeda their promise not to
host terrorist groups who are going to
attack the west is worthless isn't it
but you're on your way the queen because
that's what that's what al qaeda exists
for
exactly and then that's the risk and i
think that's that's why you know one
could be angry at the way that this
whole thing was handled we didn't have
to we go to the beginning of our
conversation um it didn't have to be
this way it could have been done more
responsibly for all its faults
we have been talking about the fault the
faults of the islamic republic the
republic was the the surest
form of of government that could if
helped
and and if the taliban had been included
in it and if if the the war had ended
um
strengthening the the the state
that would would have been the surest
way to in uh to uh to to sort of um
basically
uh
ensure that afghanistan would never be
a place for for radical elements in the
future oh that
certainty sadly does not exist and i
can't uh i i can't think of it can we
talk briefly about the economy the the
people's needs are huge and urgent about
15 million afghans are now reported to
be living below the poverty line from
what you said earlier the taliban don't
seem to care god will look after god
will dispense god will provide if if he
feels like doing that um we now know
that the new acting head of the central
bank has no formal financial training or
higher education [ __ ] mohammed idris
sounds like a disaster in the making do
do you think that they have learned
anything about running an economy
uh in the last 20 years the taliban
could still control security
institutions and and
show to their people to their ranking
file that they have still hold
all power but they should have included
technical elements they should have
included uh technocrats they should have
included um not necessarily people like
myself as with any association with the
former government with the former
government they could have just brought
totally new faces and that would have
given people more confidence and trust
they could have given the world more
confidence and trust but i think
increasingly as i said increasingly i'm
seeing that the taliban
are about to lose this opportunity once
again do you think the resistance will
continue resistance that we've seen on
the streets particularly from women
protest groups in in kabul itself
that's where
that's where the change is i think
that's where the
you know the real republic is on the
streets of kabul
and that will uh you know once again if
if it hasn't already um
ranked bills bills in the in in the
taliban's minds then they should because
governing afghanistan today will not be
easy the 1990s was a completely
different time resistance will
absolutely continue that uh
i think that is why
um it's a it's a i see it as a total
mistake and it would be short-lived if
the taliban do not
um really
encapsulate the
the new society
but at the end of the day can can any of
the gains of the last 20 years survive
i'm talking about the education of girls
and women the three and a half million
girls who went to school 27 of mps were
women life expectancy for women actually
went up by 10 years
will any of that survive certainly not
the
political participation of women from
all accounts
uh it could once again as i said i still
even though i am worried and i sound
worried uh i i'm i'm sure um
about the fact that that opportunity is
slipping but
but if the taliban insist on on just
being as pure and monolithic in terms of
their governance as
as it seems today
then then it would be very hard for them
to govern it would be very hard for them
to ensure because radical elements are
increasingly even we're seeing it in the
last two three weeks
the there was one there was there was
one kind of a taliban presence on the
street today it's a different uh kind
um so there would be my the fear is that
when you
when you do not provide that sort of big
cover of
of of through leniency inclusivity
and an intention to sustain the gains
and protect them then what happens is
below people just then compete on being
more radical than the others and then
and then that will then translate into
policies being
being changed
there are commitments of course the
taliban have made on
on women's rights on protecting some of
the gains
but you don't
you won't place much value on that well
they are shooting themselves in the foot
it wouldn't have changed them uh
in any way there they wouldn't have been
a threat to their
uh to their rule if they had allowed uh
those things if they had
made it very clear that that's what
their priority is and and that today's
afghanistan has changed and they will
not be the taliban of the 1990s they're
saying that in in words but we have see
we need to see that in action and we
haven't seen uh
in the last few weeks uh a lot of that
in action so i worry for the gains to be
lost but at the same time i think um i
think the after the people this time
will will fight the people will not just
let it
go like like the 1990s jawad luden i'm
afraid we're running out of time thank
you very much for being with us on
conflict zone
you're most welcome mr sebastian good to
talk to you
[Music]
[Applause]
you